Described by medical professionals as bogus,
“a solution in search of a problem,” and
“a triumph of ignorance over science,”
the method of removing earwax that employs
heated beeswax, known as ear candling, is
a staple treatment for many when their ears
get clogged up.
But does ear candling actually work?
Adherents of the practice claim that ear candling
was a part of traditional medicine from across
the ancient world, including supposedly used
by the Egyptians, Chinese, and Native Americans,
with one manufacturer of the wax tubes, Biosun,
going so far as to refer to their product
as “Hopi Ear Candles,” despite that the
Hopi Tribal Council has come out and stated
“[ear candling] is not and has never been
a practice conducted by the Hopi tribe or
the Hopi people.”
Whatever its true origins, for those unfamiliar,
the process of ear candling is relatively
straightforward.
First a sheet of cotton is coated with beeswax
(and sometimes a bit of honey and/or other
herbs as well).
Sturdy enough to roll into a narrow cone shape,
the narrow end of the cotton cone is set in
the patient’s ear, and then the other end
is set on fire.
As it burns, adherents often claim that the
flame creates a heated vacuum that pulls earwax
from the ear into the tube.
Others go further and note that the negative
pressure produced by the flame via the cone
also draws out “toxins” from the bloodstream.
After about 15 minutes, the flame is doused
and the cone removed.
To view the result, a stick is shoved through
the cone, which pushes out ash and a fair
amount of melted wax that is darker than the
original beeswax, and generally claimed to
be a mixture of ear wax, beeswax, and ash
from the cotton.
So does ear candling actually work?
To begin with, Dr. Lisa M.L.
Dryer notes that ear candles don’t actually
create any real suction and that, “Since
wax is sticky, the negative pressure needed
to pull wax from the canal would have to be
so powerful that it would rupture the eardrum.”
Travis Berry, director of marketing and sales
at Wally’s Natural Products, a maker of
ear candles, actually concurs with this assessment,
noting that the earwax removal does not happen
while one is being treated with an ear candle,
but, he claims, after: “The smoke particles
seem to bond with ear wax particles, and allow
them to fall out as flakes.
They fall out naturally while you’re sleeping,
showering, driving to work.
Your body does this anyway.
Ear candles merely aid the body in removing
excess ear wax.”
So what does the hard data from research say
about ear candling?
Studies to date have definitively shown that,
apart from the more obvious outlandish claims
of this method purifying blood being categorically
false, ear candles don’t remove any earwax
from the ear save perhaps surface wax that
may get stuck to the tube.
For example, in one such study, researchers
first performed the technique correctly then
separately burned the candles without placing
them in an ear.
The result?
The composition of the clump of melted wax
was identical and no change in the state of
wax within the ears in question was observed,
with the researchers concluding, “The wax…
from an ear cone is not from the ear . . . but
rather is a product of the candle itself.”
In a 2007 paper, Cerumen Impaction, published
in the American Family Physician, Dr. Daniel
F. McCarter et al. summed up the method’s
effectiveness based on their research stating,
“ear candles neither created suction nor
removed wax and actually led to occlusion
with candle wax in persons who previously
had clean ear canals.
Primary care physicians may see complications
from ear candling including candle wax occlusion,
local burns, and tympanic membrane perforation.”
In another 2007 paper, Ear Candling: Should
General Practitioners Recommend It?, published
in the Canadian Family Physician medical journal,
the researchers concluded:
Ear candling appears to be popular and is
heavily advertised with claims that could
seem scientific to lay people.
However, its claimed mechanism of action has
not been verified, no positive clinical effect
has been reliably recorded, and it is associated
with considerable risk.
No evidence suggests that ear candling is
an effective treatment for any condition.
On this basis, we believe it can do more harm
than good and we recommend that GPs discourage
its use.
As these researchers noted, more than just
ineffective, ear candling can be dangerous
due to the flame burning so closely to the
patient and the heat of the dripping wax.
As a result, facial burns and other injuries,
particularly from burning wax inside the ear
canal, are occasionally noted, though as far
as we could find no widespread study has definitively
reported what the injury rates are for ear
candling.
But as an example of the type of injury sometimes
incurred, in the aforementioned 2007 study,
it was noted that in one case the practitioner
accidentally allowed a significant amount
of hot wax to enter the ear canal of the individual
she was performing the method on.
Seeking medical attention, the patient ultimately
had to be put under general anesthesia to
remove the wax that had flowed deeply into
her ear.
Beyond burns, a perforation of the woman’s
ear drum was discovered once the wax was removed.
Subsequent tests revealed that she had hearing
loss in that ear; at her one-month follow-up,
her hearing had not improved.
So how should a person with an ear clogged
with earwax remove it safely?
First – don’t use Q-Tips!
Physicians (and even the makers of said product)
have advised- and been completely ignored-
for decades that Q-Tips, like other long,
thin objects, can easily puncture an eardrum.
Beyond this, regular use of Q-Tips, while
doing a decent job of cleaning the surface
of the ear canal, has a tendency to result
in a buildup of wax deep in the ear from the
Q-Tips pushing some of the wax further in.
Instead, for cleaning the outer surface of
the ear canal, soft tissue paper rapped around
the finger can suffice.
As for cleaning out a build up of earwax deep
in the ear canal, assuming one doesn’t have
a perforated ear drum and your shower pressure
isn’t too strong, lightly rinsing your ear
with near body temperature water (too cold
or hot can cause dizziness) for as long as
necessary is a relatively effective method
of ear wax removal.
Alternatively an even better water method
is the somewhat overpriced, though still a
lot cheaper than a doctor’s office visit,
Elephant Ear water bottle sprayer that many
doctor’s offices use for cleaning ears.
The general method here is to fill the spray
bottle with warm water, tilt your head slightly,
partially insert the tip into the ear canal,
and begin vigorously spraying at various angles
until the built-up ear wax is flushed out.
For extreme blockages, it may take several
minutes of spraying to completely remove the
ear wax, but this will eventually get the
job done.
To speed the process up, over-the-counter
ear wax softeners may help soften the wax
up before spraying, though these aren’t
strictly necessary.
Just plain warm water will do the trick eventually.
All this said, for most people the majority
of the time manually removing ear wax from
the ear canal is not necessary and can even
be harmful if done too often as earwax serves
a few useful purposes, such as working as
a lubricant and helping to stop your ears
from becoming too dry and itchy.
Its stickiness also helps trap dirt and other
such foreign invaders to your ears.
In the end, most of the time for most people
ear wax is naturally pushed out on its own,
with mere surface level cleaning in a bath
or shower being sufficient to tidy up the
ear.
Of course, ultra-dry climates, ears that produces
excessive wax or are oddly shaped internally
or other such abnormalities may make it so
the occasional buildup occurs, resulting in
diminished hearing or even full blockage of
the canal.
For those times, rather than reaching for
the Q-Tips, which long term will exacerbate
the problem, or attempting the useless ear
candling method, (assuming you don’t have
a perforated ear drum) try something that
actually works like the Elephant Ear sprayer,
your shower head (with pressure turned down
to a comfortable level), or simply head to
the doctor’s office and they can clean
your ear
out in short order.